12 heures d'entraînement par jour 6
jours sur 7 sous le soleil
ibérique dans ce camp d'entraînement
militaire du nord-est de l'Espagne une
cinquantaine de soldats Ukrainiens
âgés de 21 à 60 ans ce familiarise
depuis un mois au léopard 2 à 4 des
chars plus modernes que ceux qui
manœuvrent déjà sur le front
ces soldats Ukrainiens viennent tous
d'unités blindés mécanisées ça facilite
beaucoup les choses ils ont tous des
connaissances sur les charges de combat
et ça les a aidés à retenir tout ce que
nous leur avons montré durant la
formation à présent ils peuvent partir
pour l'Ukraine avec une connaissance
plus qu'a acceptable du chariotard 2 à 4
en février le Premier ministre espagnol
Pedro Sanchez avait confirmé au
président ukrainien l'envoi de
scie-charles léopard 2 à 4 et
possiblement quatre autres plus tard
notre objectif est de synchroniser la
livraison des léopards avec l'achèvement
de la formation des soldats ukrainiens
la Pologne l'Allemagne la Suède ou
encore la Finlande ont aussi promis de
livrer des chars léopards à l'Ukraine
prochainement
fin de la formation ce mercredi après
quoi ces soldats Ukrainiens retourneront
combattre sur le front